[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui l'initiative des
trois maires une alliance informelle de
12 pays d'europe centrale et orientale
qui ont l'ambition de peser sur le plan
régional tant économiquement que
géopolitiquement comment se présente la
coopération entre les membres de cette
initiative le 3 juin un forum
parlementaire a été organisée par huit
états membres de l'alliance au menu les
possibilités d'attirer de nouveaux
investissements et la réalisation de
projets communs dans les domaines des
transports de l'énergie et du numérique
une avancée de taille selon certains
participants l'activité et de
l'initiative risque de bouleverser les
positions russes et chinoises dans la
région la diversification énergétique
tant soutenu par les états unis qui
vendent leur gaz naturel en europe
pourrait faire chuter les importations
de gaz russe
côté numérique qui l'alliance rejoint le
plan américain de réseaux propres et
appelle à éviter de coopérer avec le
géant du numérique chinois ou avec
malgré le développement actif de
l'alliance son avenir reste ambiguë en
croatie et en bulgarie le débat se
poursuit sur la nécessité de cette
adhésion est au contraire de nouveaux et
aspire à devenir membre de cette
alliance plus crenn et la moldavie
cependant leur chemin vers l'adhésion
est pour l'instant barré étant donné
qu'ils ne font pas partie de l'ue
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette alliance ambitieuse un
plein coeur de l'europe c'est le blitz
créé en 2016 à l'initiative de la
pologne et de la croatie l'initiative
des trois mais réunit douze pays de l'eu
formant un triangle entre la mer noire
et les mer baltique et adriatique
les membres de l'alliance représentent
ensemble 30% de la surface du lieu 25 %
de sa population et près de 20% de son
pib
le premier objectif de l'alliance et de
dynamiser la croissance économique de la
région pour cela les membres de
l'initiative met en place des dizaines
de projets dans les domaines des
transports de l'énergie et du numérique
et en plus des enjeux économiques
l'initiative des trois maires a aussi
l'ambition de devenir une puissance
géopolitique régionale le financement de
tous ces projets s'effectue via un fonds
d'investissement créé en 2019 la pologne
et la roumanie
il contribue à plus de 500 millions
d'euros et nombre de partenaires ont
suivi le pas washington qui est pourtant
loin des trois maires en question
approuve l'année dernière une aide de
plus de 250 millions d'euros à
l'initiative une alliance prend de plus
en plus forme en europe centrale et
orientale l'initiative des trois maires
lancé il ya seulement cinq ans elle a
pour objectif de créer un nouvel axe
économique transports énergie numérique
plus de 70 projets sont en cours de
réalisation dans de différents domaines
allié fiable du projet les etats-unis y
voit surtout un moyen de contrer les
influences russe et chinoise dans la
région
washington prône la réalisation de
projets visant à réduire la dépendance
des états membres vis-à-vis du gaz russe
en ce qui concerne la chine les pays de
l'alliance soutiennent le plan américain
de réseaux propres appelant à éviter
toute coopération avec ou avaient
pourtant la viabilité de l'alliance
suscite des doutes
la bulgarie et la croatie continue de
s'interroger sur la nécessité de
participer à celle ci deux autres états
souhaitent rejoindre au contraire le
bloc l'ukraine et la moldavie pourtant
la porte leur sera fermée jusqu'à ce
qu'elle devienne
ambre de lieux alors quelles sont les
perspectives qui se dessinent devant
l'initiative des trois maires comment ce
bloc pour at il changé le paysage
géopolitique régional comment la russie
la chine défend tel leur position face à
l'activité de l'alliance pour répondre à
toutes ces questions nous rejoignons
pierre leur un écrivain et spécialiste
du monde post soviétique et de la russie
messieurs leur un bonjour bonjour
pourquoi selon vous les initiatives des
trois mères est elle apparue sur
l'échiquier régional
quels étaient les principaux motifs de
sa création
je crois que il ya simplement une
convergence d'intérêts au départ en tout
cas entre les pays
les anciens pays de l'europe de l'est
qui était sous domination soviétique
plus l'autriche qui est venue se greffer
parce qu'elle a un intérêt économique à
le faire et il s'agissait au départ dans
le contexte but durcissement de la
politique européenne après laffaire
d'ukraine et le rattachement de la
crimée à la russie il s'agissait de
comment dirais-je devra alors is est ce
que ces anciens pays sous domination
communiste pendant plusieurs décennies
pouvait mettre en commun de manière à
asseoir un nouveau développement à
établir des lignes de communication en
europe qu'ils ne soient plus est ouest
mais également nord-sud et de l'ain
cette initiative qui se réduit en gros à
une entente économique entre les
entreprises entre les gouvernements mais
très floue mais surtout deux projets
majeurs une voie de transit et de et de
transport du nord au sud c'est à dire de
la mer baltique jusqu'à l'adriatique et
à la mer noire par la grèce et surtout
une voie énergétique qui transporte
ray du gaz naturel liquéfié depuis le
port de la baltique clé ipp et gien
juste que le l'ensemble de l'europe est
également depuis un port en adriatique
en croatie qui ferait de même donc ce
disons que ce corridor énergétique
serait une réponse à au doute qui
émergeait à l'époque sur le destin du
gazoduc north stream 2 qui était en voie
de mise en place mais cette initiative
est restée elle comprend aujourd'hui 12
membres qui selon vous il jouait le rôle
moteur
le rôle moteur et jouée par deux pays
qui sont à l'initiative de l'initiative
justement des trois maires ce sont la
pologne et la croatie
il se trouve que le président polonais à
alger duda et la présidente croate
tallinn d'un robert petit à petit arbre
reach ont été élus en 2015 ils sont
arrivés au pouvoir
à ce moment là et donc dans leur esprit
en particulier dans l'esprit du
président duda c'était le moment de
lancer cette initiative qui faisait dans
l'esprit polonais référence à la volonté
polonaise de créer une sorte de
fédération qui ré justement de la
baltique jusqu'à la mer noire et à
l'adriatique est qui et qui date d'avant
la seconde guerre mondiale et même bien
avant
et ces deux pays pour des raisons
sensiblement différente voulait sortir
d'une sorte de bon sens en tout cas pour
la croatie d'une sorte de de réduction
dans un coin de l'europe puisque
effectivement la croatie se trouve
relativement au sud est relativement
isolé et la pologne
en revanche voulait plutôt asseoir une
forte deux n'ont pas de domination parce
qu'on n'est pas dans les problèmes de
domination mais sur
ou une prééminence économique qui
pouvait lui être profitable et c'est
cela qui a fait que l'initiative est née
merci beaucoup monsieur laurin nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore un nouveau format de coopération
pour l'initiative des trois maires le 3
juin le premier forum interparlementaire
est organisé par visioconférence un
événement plutôt symbolique qui
rassemble les chefs du pouvoir
législatif de huit étapes qui font
partie de l'initiative des trois maires
parmi les sujets abordés des projets
d'infrastructure et les moyens d'attirer
les investissements privés et même si
aucune décision n'est prise les
participants du forum et voit quand même
une étape importante du développement de
l'initiative
aujourd'hui nous avons une occasion
exceptionnelle d'en discuter entre les
chefs de parlement ainsi cette dimension
parlementaire est en train de naître
cette dimension parlementaire pourrait
faciliter la mise en place d'un nouvel
axe économique et énergétique nord-sud
en europe centrale et orientale un
objectif clé de l'alliance car les
liaisons existantes est ouest remontant
à l'époque de la guerre froide ne
suffisent plus selon les membres de
l'initiative
il compte désormais réalisé plus de 70
projets d'infrastructures dont la
majeure partie concerne le domaine des
transports routes chemins de fer ponts
tunnels
parmi les autres objectifs la défense
des intérêts géopolitiques comment
l'alliance ne précise pas toutefois
lesquels mais la presse occidentale est
unanime sur le sujet selon elle il
s'agit principalement de contrer les
influences russe et chinoise dans la
région
ce n'est donc pas par hasard si le
projet bénéficie du soutien diplomatique
des états unis qui participe souvent aux
sommets du groupe
les etats unis ont été un fervent
partisan de l'initiative des trois
maires depuis le début et elle répond à
bon nombre de nos priorités communes
l'une de ses priorités la
diversification énergétique des pays de
l'alliance qui importent largement leur
gaz en provenance de la russie afin de
contrer les positions de celles ci les
états unis proposent aux membres de
l'initiative leur propre au gaz naturel
liquéfié en octobre 2020 washington est
allé jusqu'à approuvé quelques 300
millions de dollars pour soutenir le
volet énergétique de l'initiative au
moins trois terminaux de gnl sont en
cours de construction en croatie en
estonie et en lettonie
l'initiative prévoit aussi la
construction d'une infrastructure
gazière qui permettrait l'intégration
des systèmes gazier des états membres de
l'initiative l exportation du gaz vers
d'autres membres de l'union européenne
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas étonnant que la
russie voit d'un oeil sceptique la
formation et l'activité de cette
nouvelle alliance
si certains initiateurs mois dans cette
idée la possibilité de rallier les pays
de la région autour du principe de
contenir la russie alors bien sûr nous
ne pouvons l'accepter
de toute façon ébranlé les positions
russes ne sera pas facile sur le marché
énergétique de la région avec la
construction du gazoduc turc stream à un
certain nombre d'acteurs régionaux
expriment leur attachement aux achats de
gaz russe la hongrie qui compte en
bénéficier dès octobre 2021 signé en
juin dernier un nouveau contrat avec
gazprom pour une durée de 15 ans selon
bloomberg la bulgarie reçoit déjà du gaz
russe via un nouveau gazoduc avec une
réduction de 40% offerte par moscou
l'autre membre de l'initiative qui
s'appuie largement sur le gaz russe et
la slovaquie en 2020 ces importations
ont battu des records 8,6 milliards de
mètres cubes a pourtant la russie n'est
pas la seule dans le viseur de
l'initiative des trois maires ce
partenariat à risque en outre de
perturber les positions chinoises dans
la région principalement sur le marché
de la 5g
en octobre 2020 les pays de l'initiative
annoncent leur soutien au plan américain
de la 5g qui appelle à éviter toute
coopération avec des vendeurs de télé
comme non fiable une catégorie sous
laquelle washington sous-entend les
producteurs chinois huawei et zte
néanmoins contrairement à la russie la
chine évite de critiquer directement
l'alliance car une partie notable des
projets d'infrastructures que les
membres de l'initiative met en oeuvre
coïncide avec la nouvelle route de la
soie que pékin promeut activement dans
la région en ce qui concerne ou à veille
le gouvernement chinois se dit être prêt
à se battre jusqu'au bout
dans son activité s'appuie
principalement sur la hongrie qui
héberge le plus grand centre logistique
du géant des télécoms chinois en plus de
ça les autorités hongroises annonce la
construction d'un nouveau centre ou
avaient dans leur pays l'autre projet
ambitieux et la création d'un nouveau
hab logistique de ou avait en slovénie
qui permettrait d'avoir accès à 19
marchés nationaux européens alors quel
avenir se dessine pour l'initiative des
trois maires quels sont les projets
d'infrastructures en cours de
réalisation qu'il défis se posent devant
les membres du groupe la réponse après
la pause
[Musique]
un nouvel axe géopolitique nord-sud se
dessine en europe
fortement soutenu par les américains
l'initiative des trois maires promeut un
certain nombre de projets économiques et
à l'ambition de devenir un poids de
taille géopolitique un début assez
prometteur pour cette alliance qui
fêtera ses cinq ans cette année
l'initiative des trois maires reprend
une ancienne idée née en pologne entre
les deux guerres mondiales
le projet de l'inter mario hommes
prévoyaient de fédérer les pays d'europe
centrale et orientale afin de faire face
aux deux géants européens qui étaient
l'urss et l'allemagne
pourtant il n'avait pas pu se
concrétiser à l'époque un certain nombre
de pays concernés voient dans ce projet
une menace pour leur indépendance
l'éclatement de la seconde guerre
mondiale mais tu crois sur ce projet
l'idée d'une telle alliance renaît de
ses cendres en 2014
un groupe de réflexion américain
atlantic council publie un rapport qui
explique la nécessité de construire un
corridor nord-sud d'énergie de transport
et de télécommunications
le principal motif en est la dépendance
de la région aux voies de communication
traditionnels est ouest datant de
l'époque de la guerre froide
cette analyse sert de point de départ à
une réactualisation du projet par les
présidents polonais andrzej soudas et
croates colinda grabar kitaro beach tout
nouvellement élu en 2015 en octobre de
cette année-là en marge d'une réunion
des nations unies à new york
une première réunion se tient à
l'initiative de la présidente crottes
des représentants de 12 pays d'europe
centrale dont le président polonais sont
présents ainsi que des membres de
l'atlantic council
le futur format de l'initiative est
décidé or formellement l'initiative des
trois maires et lancé en août 2016 lors
du forum de dubrovnik en croatie
la déclaration finale dresse les grandes
lignes de coopération à venir entre les
12 pays représentés à savoir dans les
domaines du transport de l'énergie et du
numérique
tu es le sommet suivant qui se tient en
juillet 2010 est à part sauvy les états
unis s'intéressent de plus en plus au
projet le président américain donald
trump qui vient en personne à la
rencontre affirme la volonté de
washington d'en devenir un partenaire
stable à cette occasion écrit un forum
d'affaires de l'initiative des trois
maires qui doit se tenir chaque année en
parallèle du forum principal
l'année 2008 marque une étape importante
dans le développement de l'initiative
lors du sommet de bucarest organisé en
septembre 48 projets d'infrastructures
prioritaires sont définis parmi les plus
ambitieux sont la vie à carpathia une
autoroute nord-sud de la lituanie à la
grèce ou encore la vie à baltique à une
autoroute doublée d'une voie ferrée
reliant les pays baltes à la pologne un
autre projet d'importance consiste à
relier les terminaux de gnl construits
ou en voie de l'être en pologne en
lituanie en croatie et en roumanie
le troisième volet notable comporte le
développement de réseaux de fibre
optique et d'infrastructures pour la 5g
afin d'assurer le financement de ses
projets un fonds d'investissement est
créée en 2010 9 à 10 y at-il la banque
nationale de développement polonaise en
partenariat avec la banque romaine
d'investissement
l'enveloppé initiale est de 500 millions
d'euros avec l'objectif d'atteindre les
5 milliards parallèlement avec la
création du fonds la réalisation de
certains projets connaît des avancées un
rapport publié en 2010 9 montrait que
trois projets sur 48 avait été achevée
et que 15 seulement avaient connu un
progrès substantiel
les deux sommets suivant celui de
ljubjlana en slovénie en 2019 et celui
de tallinn en 2020 se poursuivre dans la
lignée des sommets précédents avec
l'ajout de nouveaux projets
d'interconnexion le fonds
d'investissement augmentent peu à peu
son capital avec la participation de
nouveaux pays
les etats unis quant à eux annoncent en
2020 qu'ils vont y contribuer à hauteur
de 300 millions de dollars
l'initiative des trois maires attire
l'attention régionales ainsi les pays
voisins aspire à rejoindre l'alliance
comme la biélorussie qui montrait de
l'intérêt à ces initiatives énergétiques
avant l' escalade de tension avec le en
2020 ou encore la moldavie et l'ukraine
dont les aspirations reste constante
[Musique]
nous soulignons notre volonté de
renforcer notre coopération avec les
pays partenaires dans l'europe du sud
est et dans la région de la mer noire
dans ce contexte nous réaffirmons notre
intérêt dans l'adhésion à l'initiative
de trois maires de fait cela fait cinq
ans déjà que l'ukraine s'intéressent à
ce bloc
elle a même été invité à son sommet en
2016 pourtant il n'est pas question
d'une adhésion pleine et entière
c'est ce qu'a expliqué la diplomatie
polonaise en 2019
le président zelensky a demandé s'il est
possible pour l'ukraine de rejoindre
l'initiative des trois maires à cette
étape cela n'est pas possible puisque la
participation est limitée aux membres de
l'union européenne
ce qui n'empêche pas les membres du bloc
d'envisager d'aider l'ukraine via les
mécanismes de l'initiative l'annoncé
faite en mai dernier par la présidente
estonienne en plus nous pouvons utiliser
nos possibilités pour aider l'ukraine à
se rapprocher de nos économies et de
notre vision de l'avenir de l'europe
initiative des trois mères peut t'aider
dans ce contexte même si l'ukraine n'est
pas membre de l'ue eux elles pourraient
donc recevoir une assistance financière
des fondations liées à l'initiative
d'ailleurs les membres de l'ue eux
s'intéressent aussi à l'alliance comme
l'allemagne par exemple elles étaient
initialement sceptiques face à l'
initiative perçue comme une menace
potentielle pour la coopération gazière
entre berlin et moscou
mais grâce aux efforts diplomatiques de
la pologne
cette méfiance de berlin se dissipe peu
à jo en 2018 la délégation allemande
participe pour la première fois au
sommet de l'initiative une apparition
devenu depuis régulière je crois qu'au
sein de l'union européenne aussi il
s'agit d'un signal important qu'un pays
comme l'allemagne ne regarde pas
seulement à l'ouest mais
et par dessus tout regarde de plus près
vers ses voisins de l'europe de l'est
en dehors de l'ue c'est ce que nous
appelons la nouvelle politique orientale
à bruxelles la perception du bloc a
évolué dans une direction similaire
d'après les membres de l'initiative le e
la voyez d'abord comme une potentielle
structures concurrentes
or depuis 2018 les autorités européennes
contribuent financièrement à
l'initiative et participe régulièrement
à ses sommets
au début il ya eu beaucoup de
scepticisme duo malentendus et aux
clichés selon lesquels si quelque chose
se passe en europe centrale sans le
contrôle de bruxelles berlin et paris
il faut être sceptique maintenant que
nous avons clarifié la situation et que
nous travaillons avec bruxelles et les
allemands le vent est en train de
tourner l'initiative des trois maires
suscite aussi de l'intérêt en dehors de
l'union européenne ainsi selon
l'annoncent polonaise en février dernier
des investisseurs japonais souhaiterait
participer au projet du bloc
cependant son ami reste floue car des
dissensions persistent même parmi les
membres existants ainsi en croatie le
premier ministre et le président ont une
vision diamétralement opposées de
l'initiative l'un et pour l'autre est
résolument contre
au dernier sommet en septembre le chef
du gouvernement croate plein kovic
réaffirme l'attachement aux objectifs du
bloc et annonce une contribution de 20
millions d'euros à la fondation commune
ce qui fait enrager le président
milanovic très critique de l'agenda de
l'alliance depuis sa campagne électorale
je m'oppose à ce que la croatie donne
même un centime à cette initiative avant
qu'on ne voit clairement quoi où et
quand je ne vais pas participer à l'
isolement de la russie de cette manière
je considère ceci comme stupide et
néfaste pour la croatie histoire
similaire en bulgarie où le président
accuse le premier ministre de vouloir
saper la participation de sofia à
l'initiative même si le bloc ne
fonctionne pas encore à la hauteur des
attentes
il génère déjà des tensions dans la
région et au-delà
l'initiative des trois maires va-t-elle
enfin décoller en tant que force
régionale ou restera-t-elle une
plateforme secondaires limités sur le
plan économique pour y voir plus clair
nous rejoignons à nouveau pierre leur un
écrivain et spécialiste
monde post soviétique et de la russie
monsieur laurent pourquoi selon vous les
etats-unis soutiennent t-il si ardemment
l'initiative des trois maires il y a un
intérêt économique pour les états unis
qui est évident c'est vendre leur gaz
naturel liquéfié en europe et ils sont
en concurrence évidemment avec le gaz
russe qui lui est un gaz naturel non
liquéfié qui vient pas par gazoduc
directement de russie mais il y a
également un autre intérêt qui est
l'intérêt politique c'est à dire il
s'agit pour les états unis de maintenir
cette zone qui leur est favorable
on se souvient que depuis la la guerre
d'irak
en europe il y avait deux visions il y
avait une vision qui était soutenue par
la france et l'allemagne qui était
hostile à la guerre d'irak
mais il y avait également une vision
très favorable à la guerre qui était
tenu par lui et a dû de l'est de laurent
et ce sont ces états là qui constituent
le noyau le coeur de l'initiative des
trois maires et pour les américains
c'est très intéressant de maintenir une
sorte de cohésion autour d'eux de
l'alliance atlantique puisque ces pays
sont également membres de l'otan est ce
que cette initiative elle éloigne ses
douze pays de justement de la vision
politique
de l'europe de l'ouest disons que pour
le moment non il n'y a pas de divergence
dans la mesure où les pays de l'ouest de
l'europe sont sensiblement sur la même
ligne atlantiste et que bon en
particulier la politique européenne se
focalise beaucoup sur l'ukraine et sur
la menace que ferait peser la russie sur
l'ukraine et les états baltes qui est
une menace qui n'a pas de fondement mais
c'est pour les états européens pour les
états unis
en gros pour les pays de l'otan c'est un
moyen de renforcer la cohésion on est
toujours obligé lorsque les choses ne
vont pas très bien de trouver un ennemi
commun pour resserrer les rangs et pour
dire regardez il faut que l'on se tienne
ensemble pour faire face à un adversaire
qui est l'ami et l'ennemi commun mais
sera bien c'est la russie actuellement
il n'y a pas d'autre
il n'ya pas d'autre ennemi en europe
possible et quand je parle d' ennemi
c'est le terme qui est employée très
souvent par les responsables européens
il ne parle même pas des adversaires il
parle très souvent d'ennemis sous la
pression certainement de ce qu'ils
pensent être leur opinion publique
mais ce qui est très important c'est que
à terme et dissipe pas très longtemps
d'ailleurs parce que à l'issue du sommet
entre le président américain joe biden
et le président russe vladimir poutine
il semble qu'il y ait une amorce de non
pas de rapprochement mais au moins de
volonté de supprimer les aspérités dans
la relation de manière à pouvoir avoir
un socle de négociations sur certains
sujets qui sont d'intérêt général et de
ce fait les pays européens se trouve
pris entre la volonté de de ces pays de
l'est de l'europe de continuer à voir
dans la rue si l'adversaire et les pays
de l'europe occidentale qui
tendent plutôt à essayer de voir s'il
n'y est pas possible de négocier ce qui
est très significatif c'est que le
président emmanuel macron et la
chancelière allemande angela merkel ont
essayé de demander à l'union européenne
d'engager des négociations avec la
russie et l'union européenne a refusé
malgré le poids de ces deux chefs chefs
d'état pour macron chef de gouvernement
pour merkel
et ça c'est très significatif parce que
cela signifie que le poids de ce groupe
de pays
depuis d'autres qui viennent autour est
déterminant actuellement pour définir
une politique européenne
et ça je crois que ça ne peut pas durer
très longtemps
merci beaucoup monsieur laurin pierre
leur un écrivain spécialiste du monde
post soviétique et de la russie était
aujourd'hui dans cette émission pour
apporter son éclairage merci encore à
vous c'est parti là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]